Victoria what is your position here
technically I'm a waitress and a manager
what are you employed as a waitress a
waitress but then you manager as well
sometimes why because no one else is
here to do it wow why do you stay here I
think it's a loyalty thing I've been
here since before we even opened so I
want to see this place succeed and I
want to be able to say I'm so proud of
the place I work at and how you feeling
right now embarrassed mhm
and
used I mean Germaine is such a good
person he's not a bad guy at at
all and I want to help him as much as I
can and have put so much time and my own
money into this place soorry your own
money yeah what does that mean I bought
ice this past week because our ice maker
doesn't work it's came out of my my
pocket Jermaine can I just have 2
minutes on my own with the team please
can you get some fresh air just go for a
walk
please oh boy you're now
buying items for the restaurant yeah
that's beyond loyal he's the owner
you're not the
owner Whitney why is Jermaine lost his
way he's just never I don't think he
never really had it leader ship I can't
say that that's ever been anything that
Germaine has ever why would a guy that
can't be assertive can't be a leader
can't motivate why would you open a
restaurant of all the businesses in the
world he just wanted to make his parents
feel proud of him make his parents feel
proud with this
Incarnation oh man I didn't want him to
open a restaurant to be honest God told
him like no I think this is a badad
idea let me go get to
Marine come
[Music]
in by very depressing Jermaine do you
have any idea how to run a restaurant
not a clue not a clue this is Major
League this is money running out the
door cost that we burned to keep the
lights on and the stove's hot it's
insane like I said I didn't understand
what I was getting myself into until I
was already in it so I've been trying to
win it said don't do
it I said I'm here to help I am going to
start teaching you but you need to step
up otherwise there's no point me being
here is that clear yes sir are you
scared of
him
I've definitely been scared several
times somebody can get hurt
seriously you should not be walking in
fear you should not be living your lives
like that
absolutely I want you to speak up so
Brad can hear this cuz he needs to
understand how low we've got yes
sir I want to get them
in genten sit
down Brad you need to know what the
is going on here yeah you may be running
Bruce gear and that's the little shiny
jewel in the crown big deal
because right now you're a busy idiot
you're taking money from there to keep
this place open whilst this guy puts
himself in an early
grave months ago you got a text based on
his
behavior the night when we all quit when
Steven yielded us it was a disaster what
happened that night we were all counting
our money after hours just waiting to go
home and he was extremely drunk and he
was just telling us that brusy is better
and that we weren't doing a good job and
so we all just quit and walked out and
left him here because I mean we were all
hurt we didn't want to work here anymore
after that
happened the violent outbursts the heavy
drinking the Smashing up the tables
every member of Staff in here is
petrified and you're ignoring
it what last time I remember throwing
tables I remember everybody
laughing but yeah sure they're
petrified well when I get that text
about his behavior and I talk to him
about it he says well it was blown out
of proportion or I'm going to change or
this and that and I take his word for it
it's very frustrating that you haven't
done anything about
it and you think it's funny no I don't
think it's funny I think these people
have been repeating these things over
and over in their minds so often that
they think it's the truth I haven't
heard anybody say anything that they've
done wrong yet for every wrong thing
I've done up here I've done a 100 good
things but when you do things yourself
it's like stapling fabric that doesn't
even match the booth to the really how
about that patio out there that's got a
wood deck how about the roof over it how
about the hole in the wall right there
that we can Ser people through the patio
now it's just like well we don't clean
up around here because the owner punched
a hole in the wall back in 2007 well
guess what the owner also did he built
that damn wall you know if I build a
sand castle I'll kick it over if I
want you're the
owner an absent owner well I just think
everybody just needs to look in the
mirror for a minute it ain't my fault
that these are all alcoholics up here
you're telling me that the staff for
alcoholics yes
fact you can't just stand there and
blame your staff I'm you know
the stops on me is your responsibility
I've made mistakes I probably shouldn't
be punching those I probably shouldn't
be kicking chairs I probably shouldn't
be drinking like a have you probably
shouldn't be open
Steven cut the you're heading
for the Rocks you're taking every down
with
you and you just sat there watching it
happen and if you were friend you'd get
him help months
ago I came here to help you but deep
down inside I don't know if I can the
clock is ticking we got some big issues
here the staff are the foundation of any
restaurant so can you two give me 5
minutes with the staff do you mind sure
thank
you who's in charge honestly not really
anyone we have no guidance we have Katie
who is like the main person here right
now like the dayto day we don't have a
general manager or a head chef yeah
unbelievable I would like to know what
the problems are Katie you got really
upset at Hell on Wheels where does this
start help me to understand he leaves
it's like he's abandoned us and then
when he does come back in it's a showbo
it's everything's fine wow I don't know
if it's just because he's a experience
if he doesn't want to face the problem
if it's too much of a burden on him um I
don't know the ownership was given up on
themselves the restaurant and the staff
and that's honestly I think the reason
why we stick around is just because weti
for each other we really do stay for
each other man we could go get jobs
anywhere else but let me tell you
something you all are the reason why I'm
here now I know it may seem tough but
understand I've got your bag
okay okay
[Music]
sit down
please I've had a an amazing chat with
your staff and what I've heard is pretty
shocking there's no leadership there's
no structure I mean if I'm not here if
I'm gone half of the month I'm going to
interrupt you let's talk about you not
being here okay not by choice I'm
working uh but you have a restaurant
that's failing and you're not here again
not by choice and then there's no
infrastructure what's that you have no
managements you put all this money into
the restaurant yet you're chasing dreams
elsewhere and this doesn't seem to be
the number one priority yet it's
siphoning a lot of money if I was to
come here and just put everything into
this restaurant we wouldn't be in a
house next month you're missing my point
you're not here you're not helping when
you are here I disagree with that why'
you disagree because you're not actually
hands on you can't expect to run a
business properly when you're not here
you're not running the business well
that's not true what little business is
left your staff are running it but
they're not empowered to run it properly
that's not true though that's not
true you are so delusional I disagree
with that
Angela you don't know how to run a
restaurant you don't know how to run it
I appreciate your honesty you're
absolutely right I've had enough
for one day I've got 24 hours
to fix this place and that seems A
Million Miles Away you need to man up
and not disappear get your priorities
straight it's as simple as that now I'd
like to hear from you Tim what's wrong
with Southern Kitchen communication here
is the biggest issue we need to all be
on the same page as a team but where
does that miscommunication come from
it's between Chelsea Shane and Kellen
they argue a lot when they get into the
kitchen it's just me my mom and my
sister pretty much trying to do
everything you also have to take
accountability and responsibility too
you can't just throw it all on the
ownership in defense of the waiters I
was asking where my plate was and then
it was a your plate is coming don't
worry about your plate stop asking about
your plate there's sending food out on
different tickets so the waiters don't
know which plate to
grab I didn't see Shane in the dining
room at all is she always in the kitchen
most of the time yeah but she's not a
chef yeah I try to get her out of the
kitchen they try to get her out of the
kitchen but then they don't do it
properly when she's not back there and
what I hear right now yeah okay there a
little bit of miscommunication that may
happen but you're also
miscommunicating it's communication as a
team we're a team we all sinking each
other down it ain't just Kellen Shane
and Chelsea you're all not communicating
you're too busy in the serving station
talking and laughing or too busy at the
hostess station chopping it
up Chelsea are you saying that the staff
are lazy
absolutely
they can be and then they can come in
here and sometimes and they can work
their tails off but we've all gotten too
comfortable we've known these kids for a
long time 6 seven years they're like our
family and that's how we treat
them and because we treat them like that
sometimes I feel like they get a little
LAX but they're here to
work are
they
we've known these kids for a long time
they're like our family and because we
treat them like that sometimes I feel
like they get a little LAX but they have
to work are they I know when it's a lot
of playing going on everybody's getting
too comfortable and then when you say
something to them it becomes a problem
you know I come here to work and I come
here to make sure the work I'm doing is
a direct reflection of the establishment
I'm working working for it seems in
order for us to have an effective team
we need to all be on the same page
owners need to be able to communicate in
order for our teams to follow teams need
leaders and leaders need structures it
sounds like there's no structure in here
whatsoever I'm M can you go and get me
uh Shane please
downstairs Danel would you describe this
environment as a positive work
environment no no it's not positive at
all why not uh sometimes you come in you
don't even want to come in sometimes you
ready like all right we're going to get
screamed out
today tough when you got no Direction no
leadership and you're frazzled on a
daily basis Shane in your mind what's
wrong with the place um people aren't
taking the job seriously and they don't
see it as their livelihood cuz they've
been with me so long we've always made
payroll whether I had the bar from my
mom whether I get it from a credit card
we've always paid them and I gave them
money when their families were down
loaned them money so it has become a
thing of disrespect towards me and my
family and then when I saw screaming and
hollering about it it's like what's
wrong with her now she lost her mind I
need member staff that is being rude
disrespectful why are you employing them
they need to work you know so I don't
want to harm anybody's life you know
you're running a restaurant not a
charity I've got so many problems to
deal with how did we find ourselves in
this situation our father is an
alcoholic and needs no
help I'm being
honest ni he bought this restaurant
thinking he was about to die it was kind
of like a family Legacy and yet none of
you knew how to run it it was thrown in
our laps Chef none of us have had real
training things aren't properly done on
a regular basis we've been winging it
for 7 years no one's ever sat down with
me and taught me food CA I've learned it
on my own what I know I can understand
that you were a novice 7 years ago but
you still can push yourself I need to be
a better boss I know I'm I'm not good at
it Logan you're 20
right I wouldn't dream of throwing any
of my 20y olds in a mess like this what
keeps you here I have a Little Dream I
can see this going further I'm trying to
help out my family I'm trying to get us
to a better spot I'm trying to make a
dream Logan would go way in Beyond I
wanted to step up and make a change I
really did and Logan in your mind who is
the biggest problem in the restaurant
it's Autumn like I can't account for
anything Autumn's ever made I'm not a
cook Logan it's not being a cook you own
part of the restaurant part owner of a
restaurant you're supposed to know all
aspects of the restaurant can I speak up
yes please he's outside smoking
pot okay I was going to try to keep this
stuff
back I'm not ashamed of smoking pot it's
legal and in how many states now stop
trying to throw my out there what
about you what are you doing for this
family nothing you're taking advantage
here you show up you show your face you
don't get an award for that I didn't say
I get an award you don't even get a pen
on your shirt for that but I'm 20% owner
in the beginning you said you didn't
want anything to do with this place you
told us how you wished it burned down
bull crap how you're going to laugh at
us when it failed bull crap your aun
said that to you as soon as she saw the
cash they made at the end of the night
she said I'm on board bull crap they
know how crazy you are for your tips no
I'm not she's chased customers out of
the door because they didn't leave
enough tip
what is that right you chase customers
there yes I oh my god when there's days
I need to work and she'll tell me you're
not working tomorrow cut it out Philip's
working and take my spot for me but why
is your auntie putting Phil in front of
you cuz they're in a
relationship oh God
what is that right
Phil kind of yeah
yeah sleeping with a line cook getting
these hours in front of your own
families you like there's a huge
conflict of interest this is my third
time back I done quit three times the
only reason I'm back this time Phil to
be honest I know why you're back God God
God
God if it was up to me I wouldn't even I
wouldn't even be back if you don't want
to be here right do everybody a favor
and go thank
you you don't want to say goodbye to
your girlfriend see
you how long is this relationship with
your sister being toxic or who loves
then why are you in business together
because we're
family that is not a good enough reason
everything's put in this there is no
plan B this has to work this is all we
have it's only not three
households Amber there are a lot of
problems to fix and I've got less than
24 hours to do
it